Rather than ending on a morbid note, let's go back for a recap of the lesson.
Development closing points. If mothers are exposed to toxic chemicals while
pregnant, the cognitive and neural development of the fetus may be permanently
affected. Babies spend more time in REM sleep than adults do because there is
more neural growth going on. Children are born with a biologically based
temperament that interacts with parenting style to create attachment styles.
Attachment and emotional contact is just as important as food for healthy
development in infants and young children. The adolescent brain is still
growing and this affects teens' ability to control their impulses. The
intelligence we gain from experience does not decline as we enter late
adulthood but our processing speed, mental quickness and abstract reasoning
capabilities do. Humans develop in a similar way although the age at which we
reach developmental milestones differs from person to person.